[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 les invités une
émission vous savez pour découvrir
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département est aujourd'hui parole à
au docteur aurélie gaullienne val
chercheuse à lui vs cul et qui est sur
le point de découvrir un traitement pour
les maladies neuromusculaires un appel
aux dons est actuellement lancé nous en
parlerons avec elle dans cette émission
vous entendrez aussi sébastien vous
entendrez aussi sébastien onomo
producteur du film le gang des antilles
et qui sort aujourd'hui dans les salles
un film engagé sur un sujet méconnu pour
un producteur originaire des clés sous
bois mais on débute donc ce 7,8 les
invités avec le docteur aurélie guyane
valbon soir bon ça alors vous êtes
docteur vous dirigez un programme de
recherche au sein du laboratoire
handicap à lui levé est ce que je dis
pas de bêtises pour l'instant et vous
travaillez sur les maladies
neuromusculaires depuis des années et
vous êtes ici ce soir parce que vous
êtes sur le point de mettre à jour un
traitement pour l'ensemble de ces
maladies neuromusculaires alors moi je
le résume on va dire très grossièrement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
de façon assez simple pour qu'on puisse
un peux comprendre votre travail et des
analyses et donc effectivement on
travaille sur des traitements des
thérapeutiques de pointe
vraiment c'est de la dernière
technologie pour les maladies
neuromusculaires et neurodégénératives
en particulier on travaille sur la
maladie de duchenne l'amyotrophie
spinale et la maladie de huntington
on travaille vraiment sur des
technologies on appelle ça de la
chirurgie
la chirurgie du gène vraiment on va
aller traiter les défauts génétiques de
ces maladies et on a mis au point un
effectivement une nouvelle molécule de
dernière génération qui est très
prometteuse et qui donne des résultats
vraiment très très satisfaisant sur sur
les patients traités côte quand quand
j'explique un traitement à voir le voir
le jour c'est exagéré ou c'est vrai
c'est à dire que on pourrait bientôt
guérir totalement de ces maladies c'est
ce qu'on espère après le bientôt c'est
sûr que c'est difficile à chiffrer en
terme de temps aujourd'hui on espère
aller en essais cliniques d'ici à peu
près deux ans ensuite les essais
cliniques et les mises sur le marché des
nouveaux médicaments ces choses qui
prennent des années donc c'est pas non
plus demain qu'on va on va
commercialiser un nouveau médicament
mais effectivement ça fait maintenant
bout de 25 ans que le gène par exemple
de la dystrophie musculaire de duchenne
a été découvert et on commence seulement
vraiment aboutir à des traitements
concret donc il ya vraiment des avancées
qui sont faites aujourd'hui assez
spectaculaire et aujourd'hui du coup
vous lancez un appel aux dons c'est
forcément des recherches qui coûte de
l'argent il voulons que quatre cent
cinquante mille euros c'est un peu comme
est effectivement pour pouvoir vraiment
être aux portes des essais cliniques on
a besoin de valider ces nouvelles
molécules et donc effectivement on a
besoin d'un financement aujourd'hui sur
sur deux ans pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
aboutir et donc on a lancé cet appel aux
dons avec la fondation ups cul pour
financer ce programme de recherche donc
c'est une collecte de dons réalisés à la
fois auprès des particuliers est à la
fois auprès des grands donateurs ont
fait appel au mécénat d'entreprise
également donc voilà on espère que ça
puisse porter ses fruits et financer ces
dernières années de recherches avant les
essais cliniques chez les patients du
coup les particuliers peuvent peuvent
donner sur les quelque 450 mille euros
comme ça ça peut être impressionnant
mais tout le monde peut peut donner
selon ses moyens effectivement la
collecte chez les particuliers on table
enfin on la limite est à peu près à
10000 euros donc pour l'instant on est
déjà à 5000 euros de collecte donc on
est moins 5000 euros si elle est
particulier mais c'est pour lancer une
véritable collecte auprès vraiment des
grands donateurs et du mécénat
entreprenariale aussi donc vraiment pour
faire appel à des plus gros don donc les
deux les deux types de médecine à son
sont touchés quand on parle de maladies
neuromusculaires pour pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas forcément le milieu on
va dire de la recherche médicale on
parle de quel type de maladie comment
elle se manifeste alors en général c'est
des maladies non qui c'est une atteinte
musculaire
donc vous seront à peine
neuromusculaires c'est la commande des
nerfs au muscle et par exemple la
dystrophie musculaire de duchenne se
caractérise par une dégénérescence
progressive de la musculature donc des
enfants qui sont en fauteuil roulant
vers l'âge d'une dizaine d'années
approximativement et malheureusement
c'est une maladie qui est fatal donc une
espérance de vie de l'ordre de 20 à 30
ans seulement donc aujourd'hui c'est un
diagnostic qui est vraiment terrible
pour les parents et aujourd'hui on n'a
aucun moyen dès aujourd'hui à aucun
traitement donc c'est vraiment des
maladies qui sont dévastatrices et un
pour les enfants alors justement pour
faire un don rappelle peut-être le site
internet comme la les malades tout à
fait sur le site de la fondation ups qu
est donc c'est en première page de la
fondation ups cul pour financer ses
travaux de recherche c'est très simple
il suffit de
cliquer pour faire un bon elle et les
plus petits dons sont les bienvenus
tout le monde peut porter cette pierre
rigaud aussi aller sur le site internet
www.elan.com tout à fait ça ces sites
vraiment de qu'on a mis en place pour la
collecte de dos qui on rappelle que les
dons sont déductibles des impôts donc
c'est une bonne
c'est important dans cette période aussi
donc on joue effectivement là dessus je
pense que tout c'est important pour tout
le monde de pouvoir défiscaliser un peu
donc autant en profiter pour faire une
bonne action alors hasard du calendrier
ou pas ce week-end c'est aussi le
téléthon c'est une opération qui compte
quand vous oui oui ça compte beaucoup
c'est effectivement les mêmes
thématiques donc on travaille sur les
maladies neuromusculaires qui sont aussi
financé par par le téléthon nous on n'a
pas de financement direct du téléthon
c'est pour ça qu'on est obligés de
trouver d'autres financements pour
vraiment ce type de molécules mais oui
c'est effectivement la période de
l'année où on fait appel et ingénieurs
hésitent et de tout le monde merci
aurélie boyaval d'avoir répondu à nos
questions on rappelle de coûts pour
faire un don le site de la fondation de
l'ue vs cul ou alors et lots
asso.com merci beaucoup d'être venu
[Musique]
deuxième invité de cette émission on
change la complètement de sujets
sébastien onomo bonsoir on sort vous
êtes originaire des clayes-sous-bois
producteur d'un film qui sort
aujourd'hui dans les salles le gang des
antillais et c'est un film qui évoque
une période méconnue de l'histoire de
france le bumidom soit le bureau pour le
développement des migrations dans le
département d'outre-mer un petit cours
d'histoire pour commencer cette
interview qu'est ce que c'est que cette
période méconnue de l'histoire de france
bah je vais m'improviser du coup ouais
professeur d'histoire d'histoire le
binôme donc c'est un dispositif qui a
été mis en place
au début des années 60 par le
gouvernement de bray et qui visait
grosso modo à faire venir les
populations d'outre-mer en france
métropolitaine pour les faire travailler
dans les services publics etc les postes
les hôpitaux parce qu'il y avait un
besoin de main d'oeuvre et et a fortiori
un besoin de main d'oeuvre française est
par ailleurs ça permettait au
gouvernement de l'époque de calmer des
demandes indépendantiste qui germait un
peu partout dans dans les antilles
guyane à cette période là avec avec
cette idée de d'eldorado on va dire un
peu d'oreca exact on ne s'est pas avéré
être le cas exactement parce que le
gouvernement à l'époque avait promis à
ses populations justement qu'en venant
métropole il aurait des bon travail qui
pourrait gravir des échelons sociaux et
la réalité était tout autre
saha concerne à peu près je crois 70000
personnes entre les années 60 et 80
c'est un peu plus la pub un peu plus on
est autour de 230 mille personnes croire
alors dans le film le gang des antilles
et on suit le parcours de jimmy la
rivière qui est joué dans la vraie vie
par djédjé apali qui va connaître la
galère du coup une fois arrivé en
métropole et pour s'en sortir va faire
notamment des braquages d'où le film
gong des antilles et c'est une vraie
histoire c'est pas une histoire inventée
s'est inspiré d'une histoire vraie qui
est celle de loïc féry qui a eu cette
trajectoire un peu un peu d'un il ya un
peu et très cinématographique finalement
qui du coup est arrivé en france
métropolitaine par le bolide hommes et
et a connu cette désillusion et cette
déception et on raconte la trajectoire
de ce personnage tilly qui était au
départ un un bon gars et qui va basculer
dans le banditisme pur pour sa survie on
va voir justement tout de suite à un
extrait de la bande annonce du film
nous permettait des lyonnais dans la
colère
mais dormir aussi ça n'inquiète pas pas
ce recul me disait si tu trouves pas ta
place dans la société tu la trouveras
pas dans sa propre famille
je cherchais ne croire en plus ma poche
trouée
[Musique]
c'était fait une bonne dizaine de
bureaux de poste je me sentais comme un
semi cardiologue
plus besoin demandez je voulais plus du
petit doigt l'état je voulais sa mode
tout entière est ce qu'on peut parler
d'un film engagé ce que vous même vous
êtes engagé c est la volonté de fer
vouloir faire passer un message que de
rattraper peut-être une histoire loupé
ou qui est pas forcément raconté bacon
qu'on s'engage sur ce genre de film où
il ya une conviction qui est fortin
c'est que c'est que j'estime et à
travers ce choix artistique
d'accompagner jean claude barny le
réalisateur du film qui avait un manque
dans cette histoire française en tout
cas qui a enseigné dans les écoles et
que aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de
deux des communautés du communautarisme
et c est ce qui nous semblait important
par rapport à la résonance avec certains
certaines problématiques d'intégration
aujourd'hui c'est aussi d'expliquer
pourquoi les gens sont là pourquoi on a
cette diversité en france qu elle nous
semble un peu sous représentés et donc
c'est un des objectifs qu'on recherche à
travers ce film il ya beaucoup de gens
après avoir visionné ce film qui vous
ont dit je connaissais pas du tout cette
histoire là qu'ils ont découvert avec
avec votre film justement je dirais que
80% des gens ne connaissaient pas cette
histoire et il nous le disons en sortant
des différentes projections
qu'effectivement ils ont au moins appris
quelque chose en sortant de en sortant
de ce film ça a été difficile du coup de
produire un tel fait mais ce qu'on a
essayé peut-être de vous mettre des
bâtons dans les roues alors finalement
ça a été assez simple ça pas été assez
simple nous ça nous a pris
ça nous a pris à peu près six ans pour
présenter le film auprès du public
aujourd'hui donc ça a été un long
parcours qui a été qui a été semé
d'embûches parce qu'on a gardé cette
ligne qu'on voulait avec le réalisateur
dès le départ savoir produire un film
qui est un film d'auteur et en même
temps un film grand public avec des
codes du film grand public et puis et
puis après les comédiens en n'étant pas
connu ça a été une difficulté
supplémentaire vergne est arrivé et
aujourd'hui on est content mais pas de
pression sur jean midi vers la ligne
éditoriale du film parce que c'est un ce
jour logicielle et ouais enfin pas mais
les nomades pas de pression dans le sens
où personne ne nous a dit vous pouvez
pas parler de cette histoire non non
il n'y a pas eu de pressions de ce genre
là la pression c'était plutôt sur le
fait de basculer ou non dans dans un
film qui est 100% un film d'auteur ou un
film qui est qui est 100% un film
d'action on a toujours voulu faire un
film à la croisée des genres et c'était
le plus difficile à garder comme cap
pour parler chiffres vous disiez
récemment dans une interview 2 millions
d'euros de budget 28 jours de tournage
c'est dû être j'imagine à un rythme a
laissé à ses bénévoles tout à fait tout
à fait c'est un c'était c'était une
belle cadence et pour six ans de travail
en amont en plus je suis en accord avec
en amont et peut-être pour une semaine
en salon c'est pas juste que c'est
vraiment aller à quelles sont vos
ambitions en termes d'entrées si la
mesure et c'est difficile à mesurer mais
mais après idéalement on aimerait bien
être au dessus de 100 mille entrées pour
pour ce pour ce film là et il est tenu
de tous les éléments que vous avez cités
je sais pas si on a vu pendant l'extrait
dans la bande annonce nous avait réussi
à faire des belles des belle pioche pour
ce film il ya des acteurs qui sont moins
connus donc qu'ils le sont beaucoup plus
mathieu kassovitz notamment notamment
robert mathieu kassovitz romane
bohringer
lucien jean baptiste qui sont qui sont
venus épauler ses jeunes comédiens qui
constituent le reste du casting du film
djédjé apali vincent vers mignon eriq
ebouaney gibril pava d adam aniane quand
on s'engage dans un tel film et qu'on
s'appelle mathieu kassovitz et aussi
cette conviction la même que la vo2 de
vouloir mettre en avant une partie
méconnue de l'histoire de france
complètement complètement il ya il ya
cette conviction déjà sur la qualité du
projet et puis ensuite il ya cette
conviction que cette histoire doit être
portée aux au regard du du grand public
merci sébastien onomo d'être venu sur
notre plateau le gang des antilles et
c'est dans les salles depuis ce mercredi
30 novembre
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités une
émission à revoir groupe en replay sur
notre site internet tv fil 78 points
comme sinon rendez vous demain à la même
heure bonne soirée
[Musique]